يعتبر سوق التوابل بمدينه نيالا غربيه
السودان احد اكبر الاسواق في غرب افريقيا
واعرقها هنا في اقليم دارفور القذائف التي
سقطت عليه جراء الاشتباكات بين الجيش
والدعم السريع في احداثه الخامسه عشر من
ابريل حولت السوق الى رماد الخسائر كبيره
بحسب حديثي ليله الحصر احنا الان في سوق
الشطه يعني الخسائر بتاعتنا تفوق
التريليون حجم البضائع اضافه لذلك المباني
والممتلكات الخاصه
والمستندات وكل التفاصيل انتهت الان تحت
الركام يعني
لا نقول الا ما يرضي الله انا لله وانا
اليه راجعون على الرغم من الدمار
يحاول عيسى موسى اصلاح المكان وتلبيه
احتياجات زبائن رغم من المعاناه والتعب
ولابد لنا من انه المقدح ونعمل لاعاده
تاهيل السوق
ولكي نكسب ونعيش ونعاهل نفسنا ونرمي ما
تدمر من جراء الحرب في مجتمع يكابد للخروج
من ازمات عديده تاتي هذه الحرب هنا في
اقليم دارفور لتضيف عبئا اخر على حياته
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات